the growing demand in the it industry
can make it confusing to pick one
programming language that is suitable
and helpful for an
individual so in this video we will walk
you through the top 10 programming
languages for the year
2021 as we are nearing the end of 2020
now we have analyzed and understood the
high demand coding languages in the
coming year
this list can help you plan your career
in 2021
at number 10 we have c sharp c sharp is
an object oriented and easy to learn
programming language
it is fast and supports a large number
of libraries for rich functionality and
this makes it the next best choice after
c plus plus
c sharp programming language is
popularly known for developing windows
and its applications
and now it is also being used for
developing windows and even vr games
the companies using c-sharp as their
programming language are microsoft
amazon cyber infrastructures
incorporated among many others
according to pay scale c-sharp
developers with a few years of
experience can earn nearly 102 000
pa and in india they can earn about 10
lakh rupees pa
next up we have go go is probably the
least known of all programming languages
discussed in this video
it was developed by google in year 2007
for apis and web applications
go has recently become one of the
fastest growing programming languages
due to its simplicity go
popularly known as golang was created to
meet the needs of programmers working on
large projects
it has gained popularity among many
large it companies thanks to its simple
and modern structure and syntax
familiarity the companies using go as
their programming language
are google uber twitch dropbox among
many others
according to glassdoor golang developers
with a few years of experience can earn
nearly seventy five thousand dollars ba
and in india they can earn around 13
lakh rupees ba
at number eight we have c plus plus c
plus plus is one of the most efficient
and flexible programming languages
even though it is relatively old
language when compared to others in this
list
it has maintained its demand because of
the high performance and reliability
c plus plus was built to support
object-oriented programming and has rich
libraries
c plus is used in the tech industry for
various purposes like desktop
application development
web and mobile solutions game
development and even in embedded systems
the companies using c plus plus as their
programming language are adobe
microsoft google among many others c
plus plus developers with a few years of
experience can earn nearly one hundred
thousand dollars pa
and in india they can earn around 12
lakh rupees ba
according to glassdoor next we have the
most popular programming language in the
world
javascript javascript is the most
popular language for web development
today
highly interactive and websites and web
applications are powered by javascript
javascript was the go-to language for
front-end development it still is but
now it is also being used for server
side or back-end development with the
introduction of frameworks like node.js
the scope is also rapidly expanding in
the areas of game development
and internet of things the companies
using javascript as their programming
language are paypal
google microsoft among many others
according to glassdoor
javascript developers can easily earn up
to 117 000
pa and in india they can earn around 12
lakh rupees ba
next up we have swift swift is a general
purpose
open source programming language
developed by apple it is heavily
influenced by python and therefore
is fast and very easy to learn swift is
majorly used for the development of
native ios and mac os
applications apple encourages the use of
swift for the whole development process
and so more than half of the
applications in the app store are built
using the swift programming language
the companies using swift as their
programming language are apple
slack 9gag among many others swift
developers earn nearly 107
000 pa and in india they can earn around
12 lakh rupees ba another very popular
language is java so let's look into it
java was created by james gosling in the
year 1991
it is the most demanding programming
language evident by its worldwide usage
java is known for providing the most
number of jobs in the it industry
java has a large application based in
the industry with the applications
ranging from scientific applications
financial and banking services to web
and mobile development and desktop
application development
the companies using java as their
programming language are ibm
hcl infosys among many others java
developers with a few years of
experience can earn nearly 117 000
pa and in india they can earn around 10
lakh rupees pa
next up we have the r programming
language r was conceived by robert
gentleman and ross ihaka in 1992.
r is a comprehensive and statistical
analysis language
and it encourages developers to
implement new ideas r works best on
linux
gnu and microsoft windows the
application of rs in the field of data
science
statistical computing and machine
learning although r is difficult to
learn
it is considered as the future
programming language the companies using
r rs their programming language are
capgemini
cognizant accenture among many others
our developers with a few years of
experience can easily earn nearly 150
000
pa and in india they can earn around 9
lakh rupees pa
moving on to number 3 we have kotlin
kotlin is a general purpose programming
language
originally developed by jetbrains it is
interoperable with java and also
supports functional programming
languages
kotlin is used extensively for android
development web development
desktop application development and
server side development
kotlin was built to be better than java
and people who use this language
believe it most of the google
applications are based on kotlin the
companies using kotlin as their
programming language are
coursera pinterest postmates among many
others
according to glassdoor kotlin developers
with a few years of experience can earn
nearly 140 000
pa and in india they can earn 8 lakh
rupees pa
next we have php php programming
language was initially created for the
purpose of maintaining a personal
website
but since then it has taken over 24 of
websites globally
php language is generally used to create
static and dynamic websites and some
popular web frameworks like laravel are
built upon php
php introduces dynamic changes to a
website and makes web applications more
interactive
the companies using php as their
programming language are facebook
yahoo mailchimp among many others
according to glassdoor php developers
can earn nearly 101 thousand dollars pa
and in india they can earn around seven
lakh rupees pa on average
at first position we have python
programming language
python is the fastest growing and one of
the most popular programming languages
with reliable and well-built frameworks
it is open source and easy to learn
python is used in many areas in the
industry
django framework which is based on
python is popularly used in web
development
furthermore python has become the
preferred programming language for
machine learning
and artificial intelligence few of the
big companies that use python for
development are instagram
spotify amazon and facebook python
developers can earn nearly one hundred
seven thousand dollars pa and in india
they can earn around eight lakh rupees
pa
on that note why don't you check out the
simply learns postgraduate program in ai
and machine learning created in
partnership with purdue university
and in collaboration with ibm we'll
cover a number of topics and concepts
like statistics
python machine learning deep learning
networks
nlp reinforcement learning and much more
to help you grow in your career
and there you go those are the top 10
programming languages in 2021
with that we've reached the end of this
video do you agree with our top 10 list
is there any other programming language
that is worth learning in 2021
let us know in the comments thank you
for watching this video and stay tuned
for more from simply learn